I recently started a little support
group did Jamie group the Jewish Mothers
Anonymous group blast people we're
talking about wean our sons of a
breastfeeding my name is Mike alright
guys so I recently got a job at BuzzFeed
and my mom she's making faces she
doesn't think it's it's that hard of a
job she's not impressed all right some
cuts job that you get paid for it you
have to make a video today yes and I'm
up for the challenge
yeah you think you I know I will do it
and then you're gonna perform stand-up
okay how many minutes five minutes five
minutes okay I can talk for five minutes
I'm funny people laugh at my jokes I
kill me tell me one funny joke right now
so the guy goes to the pharmacist he
puts his penis on the table puts a
dollar no stick his penis no my mom does
this terrible Seinfeld impersonation
that just she finds hilarious what's the
deal with taxi cabs I'm going to have
the best time
at BuzzFeed I think it'll be just fun
and exciting and interesting and the
time is just gonna fly by and I'm gonna
produce a twenty five million views
video so this is the best intrest ocean
express a mild express some old
expressive land Americana
that were expressed I had to make
several coffees because this was very
complicated process okay this one is
better I don't know what to do with this
one you want to trash it carefully I
have to go find my safe space and be
productive
this is productive workspace it's like a
[ __ ] tree oh my god alright I think
it's dying the table intended for my age
go to rest and get a nap in your lunch I
did a little research on kind of what
you guys do well what what are the good
statistics and it seems that videos that
have animals in them go viral that's
true right so I was thinking how cool
would it be if we did a video where
people act like certain animals for a
day then you know like that go like like
this I didn't like do that kind of stuff
or like I could be a dog and go like pet
me pet oh yeah so we could do rooster
people we could do a cow person like
[Music]
what has been the best idea recently in
BuzzFeed farts in a jar of eBay and had
people smell them so do is this maybe
that is that getting juices going
without the charm can we do parts
without the trap just smell thoughts so
far maybe we can do a video where you
try to recognize your relative by the
smell and therefore it this is very
challenging I need to actually find
people to film in this video
excuse me I'm looking for a cast for
guys or who can recognize the farts or
girls of their significant others would
you people hated to be my cast
he's married no you know I hate to admit
it this was not as easy as I thought I
got my ID i pooed so that was good do I
got to that point but then the equipment
completely threw me off so I'm gonna
focus on my stand-up routine so that I
can at least succeed in one part of this
task comedy and really just want to be
the most supportive mic in New York City
I was not envisioning a real place I
thought that this is going to be staged
and scripted and it's not and there's
like real people in there our next comic
is making her comedy debut
hi guys my son came out to me this is
still a little sensitive you know I'm
from the old country different
generation totally different upbringing
he set me down and told me that he is
not going to medical school so my son
took me to take your parent to work day
I kid you not they have been a bad seed
it was like a really cool daycare for
older kids do arts and crafts Patrick so
then they get paid for it everything
free free coffee free candy free
massages free alcohol playroom game
rooms you know I grew up in this former
Soviet Union but I found communism at
BuzzFeed okay that was that was pretty
impressive mom I was very surprised with
myself actually people left have you
learned anything from today I've learned
that my son actually has a very
challenging job producing these viral
videos these guys are very talented my
mom's got a new special coming out on
Netflix it's called I kill me